- Hello, I'm Johanna and
I just launched a platform
for connecting companies with
social media influencers.
- Okay.
- Like a Tinder self
direct and I thought I had
kind of a unicorn and
now I'm kind of exploring
the world and say, okay
there's a lot out there.
- Oh everybody's doing it.
- But we're kind of late here,
in this part of the world,
so here I captured the market
real well in a short time.
- That's awesome.
- But I wonder how my dreams about
internationalization and getting global,
and making it to scalable,
making it bigger.
What advice would you give to me for that?
- Well a couple things, first of all,
how big is it in the market
that you're winning in?
The biggest thing that,
unless you're doing seven,
10, 12 million dollars in the Nordics
you should not be thinking about
Eastern, Western Europe, the U.S.
Too many people, like every
word out of your mouth
is the shit that I was just
talking, scalable what?
We're just all caught up in building
billion dollar, it's so stupid.
How big is your company, how much,
are you doing more than a
million Euros of revenue.
- No, we are pre-revenue,
we just launched it.
- Until you fucking make money
you shouldn't be worried about global.
- No.
So you say local markets go that way.
- VaynerMedia did 75
million dollars in revenue,
profitably, before I thought
about even going to London.
Everybody's caught,
listen, I'm telling you,
all of you, you're caught
up in bullshit propaganda.
You're not thinking about it smartly.
You make no money, and you're sitting here
worried about winning globally
and you haven't even
started winning locally.
Do you understand?
- Yeah, I'm just thinking,
is partnership the way
to go, somebody that is already there.
- No, the way to go is to
not think about it at all.
Do you understand?
Like, the way to think about it is.
- That it will happen?
- Well no, it may not, 99%
likely it won't happen.
But if you're 1% that's good
enough to actually execute,
and get to the place where you go global,
then you get to go global.
But nobody is global right away.
But everybody looks at Facebook and Uber,
Uber started in just San Francisco.
Guys, Uber spent a year and a half just
trying to figure out San Francisco.
A year and a half!
Do you understand?
- That's a long time.
- No it's not, it's a
long time in the way that
you're wired right now, a
year and a half is nothing.
(mellow music)